hello and welcome to the new ultra view
yo sauce for what seems to be primarily
hunter hunter as well as occasionally
other things but not today because we're
diving straight back into modern hunt
hunter events and at this time I'd like
to hop aboard the black whale one to
examine what's happening on the lower
decks with our favorite band of
murderous thieves The Phantom true now
for non margaritas you'll probably
remember the last time we saw these guys
was when they went to meteo City and
exterminated a band of chimera ants led
by za zon which actually resulted in
fate and becoming the interim leader of
the group due to an agreement made in
Crowley's absence whatever the case as
it turns out that didn't last too long
as he soca was successfully able to
provide krola with aina an exorcist to
remove crop because curse placed upon
him which meant the CRO though was able
to return to leading the group now of
course Hisoka did this for the sole
purpose of being able to face crow in
combat and after chasing the troop
leader crow lo did eventually accept his
challenge and the two fought in Heaven's
arena with CRO lo completely dominating
the magician after having painstakingly
prepared for the match by acquiring a
fantastic combination of nen abilities
some of which were borrowed from other
members of the troupe and if you want to
know more about this fight specifically
I do have a whole video detailing it
which I'll link in the description but
for the purpose of moving on here
essentially krohler was able to kill
hosaka after which point he announced
the troops next mission which as with
everyone else involved in the current
arc has to do with the cocking Empire
it's a quick reminder here the king of
Cockaigne nasibi Hui Goro was boldly
planning a voyage to the Dark Continent
in order to settle there and reap the
incredible benefits that the land has to
offer in this task he is bringing along
what seems to be the entirety of the
world family as well as the vast
treasures of the Empire and this is the
part that really struck pro lo seeing
this as a perfect opportunity to make
one hell of the big score
and so crawler then arranged for the
troop as it stands sneak aboard the
black whale one bound for the Dark
Continent
although once again in reality it was
actually bound for the new continent
which is a separate landmass of the
hunter Association and the original v5
nations are going to pretend is the Dark
Continent dropping out to kaki Empire
and then proceeding onwards without them
regardless crawler conveyed this
information to shall knock a troop
member whose nan ability he had to
borrow in order to face ahsoka krola
went on to ask if she'll knock needed
back which was met with a regrettably
casual or buy from Shan arc because in
truth he may have needed that power
it was far too late for him regardless
because immediately after communicating
with crow low sonic was murdered by
Hisoka and this is because he Sokka had
managed to program his bungee come hot
suit to revive him after death
thus invoking post-mortem men and having
somewhat of an epiphany as a result
deciding at the time for playing games
was over and that from now on he would
kill any member of the phantom troupe on
sight and he further made good on this
by killing caught okie and these two
were very important targets because then
an abilities being black voice and
gallery fake respectively formed a major
part of Chronos strategy in taking
Hisoka down so the deaths of shamrockin
caught Opie mean that chrono has more
than likely lost access to those hearts
ooh and thus he will not be able to
repeat his performance against Hisoka a
second time very importantly though
Hisoka goes on to say two down tend to
go a fascinating number because at this
point in time the phantom troupe to our
knowledge had less than 10 members
remaining after the loss of Shana and
caught opium and amongst them were of
course the usual suspects Fink's
Franklin fate and Nobunaga but Nolan of
she's a groove crow low and machi and
actually I want to briefly pulls a notch
either because fun fact originally took
all she had planned to kill her at this
point which makes a lot of sense because
she is on he soaked his list and she was
the first person he soaked or
encountered after being revived however
in what he claims to be a storytelling
hunch takashi decided to veto his
original decision and leave Macchio life
with the technical reasoning being that
Hisoka would have needed someone to act
as a messenger for his intentions with
the troupe but in reality it was just
him thinking that down the line Hisoka
and machi would have a far more
intriguing conclusion as for whether or
not he's thought of what that will be at
this point final that's unknown but
there you have it and there we have a
machi
for now we're still missing two members
currently there one of which is collar
toes old ik and often forgotten about
member of the troupe who joined during
the great island arc allegedly to
somehow use this as an opportunity to
get his brother back as for which
brother collar toe is referring to it's
largely unknown and a pawn to some
discussion for an entirely separate
video but during the succession walk
collar toe is still an active member of
the troupe occupying he saw his previous
number for position but Carlito is not
the only zoldak within the troupe these
days as rather surprisingly ellamy has
also joined them temporarily although it
should be noted that he has only done so
by hisoka's request I mean well I say
request it was more of a commission but
basically he Sokka hi Attila me to kill
and so as part of that he has joined the
ranks of the Phantom troop assuming the
number 11 position which was previously
held by of Hakeem and that there makes a
mighty 10 members all of whom gathered
on tier 5 of the black whale to begin
their search
tier 5 being the lowest-ranking portion
of the ship intended for general
passengers regardless this is where the
current incarnation of the troop met up
introduced Elam II and then immediately
separated with the goal in mind to
simply find and kill Hisoka
whom the troop are convinced is aboard
ship although we still have not seen him
at this point in the arc and at this
time I would also like to state that the
crawler we're dealing with here is
vastly different from the troop leader
we've experienced before in the orc new
Ark or even earlier on in the succession
war business when he faced off against
ahsoka in Heaven's arena crow low
nowadays is significantly more gloomy
and single-minded and at time seemingly
only living for the sole purpose of
killing Hisoka so the deaths of [ __ ]
and Colt Opie have taken quite a toll on
him
note that the rest of the troop is
really any different each of them by
Allah me and Kyoto have a profound drive
to exact revenge on the magician with
machi in particular being in a very
similar terrifying level of focus and
scroller but with their goal in mind the
troop then split up promising that the
next time they all meet up it will be
with he soaked his head they don't go
off individually though we break down
into a couple of small groups so first
up she's a cool and banal enough asked
to join crawler in his pursuit primarily
because they don't possess known
abilities that match up well against
Hisoka sponge ego and at this point we
also learned something very interesting
though because she's a group request
that krohler used the lovely ghostwriter
ability to read their fortunes and
provide some valuable Intel going
forward however krohler reveals that
this ability has disappeared from his
book implying that the original owner
nan Lestrade is now dead and while this
particular part is pure speculation it
would make a lot of sense if he Sokka
was the one responsible for her demise
because he was well aware of this
ability and the potential dangers it
could pose to him taking on the entire
troop at once
in any case crawler Shizuku and banal
enough do successfully move on and are
currently on tier 4 of the black whale
we also have another trio formation
roaming around consisting of fate and
Fink's and Nobunaga who immediately head
to an onboard warehouse in order to
acquire their weapons which was smuggled
aboard
being Nobunaga's sword and fate hands
umbrella this is where we start to get
embroiled in some mafia business and
just to quickly summarize this aspect of
the arc there are three great mafia
powers aboard the black
one each of whom is effectively funded
by a prince of the cocking Empire and I
apologize in advance if I butcher the
pronunciation of these groups so we have
the cha cha family who come under the
jurisdiction of seven Prince losers the
Haley family funded by 4th Prince all
right Nick and the GU family who have
3rd Prince angle a as their benefactor
and essentially each one of these three
great families have jurisdiction of one
of the tiers of the ship with tier 5
being controlled by the cha family tier
4 by GU and tier 3 by Haley which is
tricky because it means a movement
between T is 5 to 3 are restricted by
mafia control what further complicates
matters is that these families are also
struggling against each other and in the
case of fate and Fink's in Okinawa they
got framed by a member of the Haley
family for the murder of a member of the
cha family although interestingly enough
the cha family became convinced of their
innocence by conversing elsewhere on
tier 5 with Franklin border who unlike
the other members is taking a more
passive approach to this whole kill
Hisoka thing with his object being that
the magician is actively trying to kill
them so if he simply waits then he Sokka
will show himself but in the meantime
Phaeton thinks in Nobunaga have formed a
temporary alliance with a child a family
with Nobunaga and Fink's in particular
eventually volunteering to kill the head
of the Haley family Marana as well as
the assassin who framed them for an acts
group the zoldak siblings have teamed up
and the two of them swiftly made it to
tier 3 of the buck wail only to be
assailed by the military well though
with illa me being a licensed Tonto
there was actually nothing they could do
against him instead Ella me and collet
Oba confronted by members of the zodiacs
who despite knowing that they were both
no members of the Phantom troupe also
declined to take any action instead miss
ice Tom simply offered them individual
rooms on level 3 requesting they
cooperate with the current alert
procedures but this encounter did open
up a very important threat of
information because miss Iceland was
well aware of the troops association
with Karaka who of course is also on
board and currently serving as the
bodyguard of 14th prince mobile news ice
Tom went on to incorrectly hypothesized
that the troop were present to take
revenge on Korra pika and while that is
not their intention at the moment that
could very much become a reality if the
Phantom troop keep making their way up
the various tiers and become embroiled
directly in the conflict with the
princes and this could trigger a
situation with Karaka who has dedicated
a large portion of his life to exacting
revenge upon the troops so while neither
party is aware of the presence of the
other at the moment I highly doubt that
things are going to remain that way and
the last of the spiders is darest machi
right now she's probably the least
interesting as oft appalling ways with
the troop she has decided to go it alone
and all that we really know is that last
we heard she had made it to the general
passenger room on tier five now she'll
be proceeding from here is unknown
however due to the fact that Takashi is
clearly saving something special for her
I have no doubt that she will be playing
a very key role in the future and that
is rather annoyingly more or less it for
the current doings of the Phantom troop
they are rapidly proceeding through the
entire ship with the presence now on
three different tiers and despite the
fact that I did heavily emphasize that
you soak her stuff after that goal is
theoretically completed they do still
intend to rob the cocking Empire of
everything they're worth with a future
goal of reaching Tier one in order to do
this which if it pans out that way
would put them smack bang in the middle
of the succession war so I think there
is a hell of a lot to look forward to
with these guys they're a nice piece of
anarchy within the arc a piece of
Anarchy that the Mafia families are well
aware of and very keen to eliminate in
most cases and I can't wait to see where
they go from here
you know whenever we eventually restart
publication but that pretty much does it
for the Phantom troops involvement in
the succession war if you enjoyed this
video and the content this channel
produced in general and please do
consider donating to the New World
review patreon because the support of
all of your amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and if patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also helps
support this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time then please do head over to
my discourse server where a wide array
of shenanigan tree takes place on a
daily basis and finally please do
comment with your thoughts on the
Phantom troop and the succession war
this has been the new world review and
I'll see you next time
[Music]
when are you gonna run out of things to
say about hunter hunter now you see this
this is a very good question as a
channel that more and more is turning
Hunter hunter centric due to the fact
that it seems to be what the viewers
want
I am currently facing the challenge of
how to sustain a one series focus
channel in the long term so for any of
you who don't know I do have another
channel called brand line review which
is entirely focused on one piece but as
a series that has you know over 960
chapters now there is literally an
infinity of ideas to talk about and at
the moment I'm not quite sure if hunter
hunter will turn out to be the same so
as part of helping to sustain a channel
like this in the long term I'd like to
ask all of you what hunter hunt related
topic do you want me to talk about feel
free to leave your idea in the comments
below
do you like yugioh yeah absolutely I
used to watch you go in highschool
because an anime based on a card game
was just such an incredible concept at
the time that was a big magic player
back then so it was fun to see Cod games
dramatized and taken to the extreme I
haven't really seen anything beyond the
first series though because GX turned me
off pretty instantly and I tried 5ds
which to be fair I did enjoy more than
what I saw ATX but it still lost me
fairly early on in the grand scheme of
things his fish a salad or box you know
I think this question is very
narrow-minded actually why can't it be
both